Whether you're cold, scared or listening to
some great music, you've likely
experienced goosebumps at some point in
your life.  But have you ever wondered why
this strange change takes over your
body?  Named after the way poultry looks
when plucked, goosebumps are a fairly useless trait in humans which have been passed
on by our ancestors.  Each hair actually
has a tiny muscle attached to it called
the erector-pili muscles and when these
muscles contract the hair stands up on
end.  This contraction creates a shallow
depression around the hair causing the
surrounding area to protrude.  And it's
the stress hormone adrenaline which
triggers this physiological change to
occur.  So what triggers adrenaline?  For
one being cold, in animals with much more
hair on their body this response helps
them to stay warm.  The standing hair is
able to trap more air and thermal
regulate it ultimately providing an
insulated barrier.  Apart from this
adrenaline is also triggered under
stressful situations leading to the
"fight or flight" response, like when
you're scared.  Cats are a perfect example,
if you give them a spook their hair
shoots up on end.
This involuntary evolutionary response
allows animals to appear bigger and
more intimidating.  But why music has the
ability to cause chills or "frisson" as
it's called is not fully understood.  One
interesting theory suggests that
elements of music such as sudden volume
changes or unexpected unique sections
induce a sub-conscious fear response.  The
body loves predictability and so
anything surprising to the autonomic
system stimulates an alarm.  But this fear
quickly subsides as our brain realizes,
"hey, it's just music".  And this contrast in
experience causes the frisson
and your goosebumps.  There are other
theories as well, ultimately the brain
is extremely complex and so a relationship
between music, emotion and physiological
responses is difficult to decipher but
in science it's okay to say that we
don't know...yet.
Got a burning question you want answered?  Ask it in the comments or on facebook and twitter.
And subscribe to more weekly science
videos.